Speaker 1: . I received a ton of questions this
week since our coverage Monday about Israeli Prime
Minister Benjamin Netanyahu being out and Naftali
Bennett being in as prime minister, and the gist
of the question is, will this actually make a
difference in terms of the Israeli-Palestinian
conflict than the answer is we just don't
know yet. There are folks who are claiming
that there is absolutely no difference between
Naftali Bennett and Benjamin Netanyahu on their
willingness to make change to the status quo when
it comes to the Israeli-Palestinian conflict. And
I think that there's some truth. There's truth to
the reality that Naftali Bennett is still a right
winger. There's no question about that, but not
from the party, Likud and a different approach.
And what you have to understand is that a
lot of what progress can be made comes down
to the coalition. The coalition, which
includes members of multiple parties,
agrees on some things. And that's typically
where the vast majority of the focuses
and on areas where they disagree, nothing tends
to happen. But the other side to this is that
no matter who you put in power in Israel,
if there is not some kind of coherent
change, Choko coherent and productive change
to Palestinian leadership, nothing will happen.
There's just no chance whatsoever. I've been
saying for years a prerequisite for change would
be Benjamin Netanyahu not being prime minister.
We've achieved that. OK, we've got someone who's
slightly less right wing now and might be
willing to make some changes and negotiate
in some areas. But on the other hand,
you still have Gaza controlled by Hamas.
You have a Palestinian Authority in the West Bank
that while certainly more willing to work with
Israel and there is a, you know, worker program
and there's much more happening than with Gaza
is at odds in many ways with Hamas and completely
unwilling Hamas, completely unwilling to cede
power to maybe allow the Palestinian Authority to
negotiate on everyone's behalf. I mean, it's like
I sound crazy even talking about this stuff
because there's zero chance that this is going
to happen. So I don't know the answer.
And as I mentioned earlier in the week,
the vast majority of the Israeli population
is concerned with and prioritizing domestic issues
like economics and wages and infrastructure,
much like we do in the United States.
And so particularly as outsiders, when we
look at, you know, a place like Ukraine. And
for us, one of the big issues we associate
with Ukraine is the conflict with Russia and
Putin versus Ukraine. And all of this stuff
for the vast majority of Ukrainians actually have
a Ukrainian friend who was just just there. And I
said, how much do people talk about? Putin
says, you know, it's casual conversation,
but the vast majority of it is there's roads that
are a disaster in Ukraine. There's roads that are
so potholed that it took four hours to go what on
a normal road would take half an hour in order to
get to the village that he was originally from.
That's what people there care about. And this is
one of the great distortions. You know, people
talk about the distortion of following foreign
policy, of, well, you take on the biases of
whatever the media in your country has. And
much of the American left likes to say almost all
American media is biased pro Israel. The real bias
is that we end up thinking that the big issues
domestically are the Israeli-Palestinian conflict
when they are not. And similarly, based on what
we hear about Ukraine, we might think everybody's
constantly talking about the situation with Putin.
Another example, I've spoken to Korean friends
who are they live in the United States but
have family in South Korea. And, for example,
at a moment when there was a big flare up with
missile launches from Kim Jong Il and I said, oh,
how's your family thinking about or dealing with
the rocket launches? And he said, you know, it's
it really if you're right there and have reason
to think that you may be in danger, it's something
that might be on your radar, so to speak. But
for his family, it wasn't really an issue. It was
jobs. It was health care. It was globalization
and and so many other things. And so the real
cognitive distortion that happens as Americans
following the politics of other countries,
as we tend to focus only on the things that are
externally facing and maybe relate to us in some
way, which is logical because, hey, we're us. And
that's in some sense what we care about. But the
internal situation is often much different.
So needless to say, I think that there is.
Five to seven percent greater possibility that
we start to see some serious negotiations when
it comes to the Israeli-Palestinian conflict, but
if and until there's a leadership change in Gaza,
I just don't see how anything is going to change.
If you have a different view, let me know.